and now it's time for the awards for
Best Screenplay original and adapted I
wrote a novel this year called shopgirl
and several thank you
and several producers came to me and
wanted to turn it into a movie and I
said look if you think you're going to
take this book and change it around and
Hollywood eyes it and give it a new
ending well that's going to cost you and
now I'm proud to introduce one of the
great stars of Hollywood mr. Tom Hanks
who in my book took a shortcut to
becoming a movie star he only made hits
so here he is mister easy pants Tom
Hanks
not since George Orwell wrote 1984 as
one has won writers name conjured more
speculation and fascination with a year
than the author of 2001 a Space Odyssey
that writer is of course sir arthur c
clarke he is he is at eighty three
perhaps the most influential science
fiction writer in the universe when Sir
Arthur adapted his short story The
Sentinel for the screen with the late
Stanley Kubrick they produced a
memorable film in which the artificial
intelligence of a supercomputer named
the Hal 9000 fired the imagination of a
generation of would be and could be
space travelers tonight from his home in
Colombo Sri Lanka in front of this
famous 2001 moonscape mural he will
present an Academy Award for
screenwriting it is my profound honor to
introduce Sir Arthur see Clark
Thank You Tommy this may not look much
like it but I'm actually in sri lanka
and it's led by o'clock tomorrow morning
it's my honor to announce the nominees
for the best screenplay based on
material already published or produced
other discreet because i can because I
know how anxious the nominees are I've
been to the same ordeal myself somewhere
in my files is the best Academy Awards
speech never delivered on behalf of
Stanley Kubrick and myself that was in
the last century the nominees in this
century are
robert nelson jacobs for chocolate based
on the novel by john harris ranked
wheedling James Sheamus je quote young
for Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon based
on the book by Frank you lose Ethan Coen
and Joel Coen for old brother where art
thou
based on the Odyssey by Homer Stephen
Gaghan for traffic based on the British
series traffic created by Simon more
Steve clothes for Wonder Boys based on
the novel by Michael Chabon and the
Oscar goes to Stephen Gaghan for traffic
award and nomination for Stephen Gaghan
if I if I made up a story where someone
like me would find himself somewhere
like this nobody would believe that
nobody here I have to thank my
girlfriend Michael our son Gardner I'd
like to thank the Academy my parents Tom
and Betty Hague of Louisville Kentucky
who are somewhere up there in the
balcony I hope I have to thank all the
film makers Steven Soderbergh the
director who took every single thing I
could give him and asked for more and
inspired me producers ed Zwick Laura
Bickford martial arts covets I have
something here that I have to I have to
make sure that I USA Pictures Scott
Greenstein Russell Schwartz and
everybody in the cast and crew and most
importantly four years ago a lot of
people raised doubt that reached out
their hands to me and helped me out and
this is for you guys thanks
the next riding award is for an original
screenplay doesn't take a great writer
displaying the category is for a
screenplay that is original and here are
the nominees in that creative endeavor
Cameron Crowe for almost famous Lee Hall
for Billy Elliot Susannah grant for Erin
Brockovich
David Franz Oni John Logan and William
Nicholson for gladiator Kenneth Lonergan
or you can count on me